[Musique]
bienvenue sur les plateaux data nous
interdirons va passer toute cette
émission avec le sociologue thomas mas
dieu qu'ils publient la favorite de
l'addiction aux jeux d'argent bonjour
thomas vous êtes enseignant chercheur à
le sca school management de shanghai
vous nous parlez d'ailleurs depuis la
chine c'est l'hiver aussi à shanghai
mais il fait un peu plus chaud qu'à
paris qu'elle tant rêver vous chez vous
le temps humain est plutôt clément plus
tôt commençons par l'image que vous avez
choisie pour illustrer notre époque elle
nous annonce un peu le contenu du livre
c'est ça va tout à fait elle est
illustrative de ce qu'on observe
actuellement c'est à dire une publicité
débridé pour les paris sportifs et elle
condense en fait cette sorte de
créativité publicitaire mise au service
du marketing qui cible d une certaine
catégorie de la population à savoir les
jeunes hommes des classes populaires et
elle est aussi révélatrice de dinde une
sorte de tournant puisque c'est à
l'occasion de l'euro de football qu'on a
commencé à prendre conscience d'abord
par des enquêtes journalistiques puis
par des réactions politiques des
problèmes qui sont liés à l'addiction en
fait aux paris sportifs donc cette
publicité elle est à la fois révélatrice
du de cette créativité mais en même
temps elle a été le déclencheur
peut-être de quelque chose d'un
changement de perspective en fait sur
les sur les paris sportifs et sur les
jeux d'argent groen par ailleurs les
intéressantes parce que si on regarde
les le petit bandeau en bas de l'image
on s'aperçoit que malgré tout on fait de
la prévention et on avertir des dangers
de l'addiction oui on donne un numéro de
téléphone mais a créé juste à côté il ya
écrit grosse cote
gros respect
et bien commençons
[Musique]
thomas dieu donc la fabrique de
l'addiction aux jeux d'argent paraît aux
éditions du bord de l'eau c'est un
travail de longue haleine sur un
phénomène dans tout le monde n'est pas
conscient en 2021 les pertes mondiales
cumulées des joueurs sont estimées à
plus de 500 milliards les français par
exemple jouent chaque année 50 milliards
c'est l'impôt des pauvres car ce sont
les classes populaires qui joue plus en
10 ans nos concitoyens addict aux jeux
d'argent a plus que doublé passant de
600 milles à près d'un million et demi
bon ce sont des estimations bien sûr
mais il ya de quoi se poser des
questions comment expliquer en effet que
l'euro millions pour ne citer que ce jeu
la rencontre un tel succès alors qu'on a
seulement une chance sur cent quarante
millions de gagner le jackpot on a plus
de chance d'être frappé par la foudre
que de remporter l'euro millions 92% des
paris ne rapporte rien quand on joue à
l'euromillions et pourtant trois
millions et demi de français jouent
chaque semaine quatre millions et demi
de britanniques pas loin de 3 millions
d'espagnols ils sont à l'ifa votre avis
non c'est pas vraiment ça en réalité ce
qui se passe ce succès de l'euro
millions et qui se dément pas et qui va
même croissant il est lié à une vraie un
véritable savoir-faire des opérateurs de
jeux et en particulier en france et là
c'est la française des jeux qui est qui
et qui
organise cette loterie et ce savoir
faire il est lié à notamment à
l'exploitation de
de nos faiblesses cognitive et ça on les
a tous on les partage tous c'est quoi en
fait c'est le fait qu' on est très
mauvais pour se représenter les
probabilités infinitésimale donc une
chance comme vous l'avez dit à juste
titre une chance sur 1
145 millions à quoi ça correspond
finalement c'est très abstrait et donc
ce qui va se passer c'est qu'on va la
français des jeux comme d'autres
opérateurs de jeux va essayer dé former
notre représentation des probabilités
et
différentes techniques alors une
première technique assez évidente c est
de mettre en avant les grands gagnants
donc la française des jeux a créé
service des grands gagnants
qui permet de mettre en avant ces
histoires heureuses donc on sait qu'il
ya deux semaines une française qui
habite en polynésie a remporté le
jackpot de 120 millions d'euros donc
c'est que ça permet de faire une sorte
de publicité gratuite on en parle et ça
râle ça rend ces grands gagnants en fait
leur destin et est rendu réel en quelque
sorte tangible mais ça déforme notre
représentation des probabilités je vous
interromps on reviendra sur les les la
séduction exercée je l'aïe qui est
extrêmement bien travaillé mais il ya
quand même eu il s'est passé quand même
h un truc dingue c'est que les jeux
d'argent sont passées d'une activité
criminelle est illicite aux loisirs
mainstream encouragé
dans le grand public et ça c'est quand
même une sacrée révolution ah oui tout à
fait c'est spectaculaire
et d'ailleurs c'est intéressant sinon
ceux effectivement si on fait un retour
un retour dans le temps et qu'on regarde
l'histoire vous avez raison la
prohibition fait c'était la norme
pendant pendant des siècles pourquoi
parce que les jeux d'argent a fait
susciter la méfiance est sans doute ce
sans doute pour de bonnes raisons mais
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'on a eu à
partir notamment des années 80 une sorte
de normalisation des jeux de les jeux
sont devenus une activité banale
mainstream et ça c'est pas fait de façon
spontanée ça s'est fait parce qu'il ya
eu des forces un certain nombre de
forces qui ont poussé pour rendre le jeu
acceptable normal et c'est ce que
j'explique dans le livre il ya plusieurs
types de force mais il ya notamment
cette capacité quelques ont vu les
industriels du jeu
les entreprises de jeu à
adopter un certain nombre de langues un
langage en fête qui leur a permis de sa
part être comme inoffensifs et
aujourd'hui ça ça prend la forme de ce
qu'on appelle le jeu récréatif c'est une
invention formidable qui a permis à ces
opérateurs de jeu de montrer en fait
c'est l'équivalent de la cigarette
lights
donc c'est le jeu qui est une activité
ordinaire qui fait partie du des loisirs
du quotidien et qui procure du plaisir à
tous les français et chacun devrait y
participer le bilan vous le racontez
bientôt mama dieu le tournant près d'aix
et 1977 en france 1 avec le loto et le
quarté c'est à dire que avant ça il y
avait la loterie nationale
une fois par semaine il y avait le
tiercé de madère et puis les riches
aller jouer au casino à la roulette et
jusqu'à des temps jusque dans les années
60 c'est même assez bien vu quand on est
riche de de perdre sa fortune à la
roulette aujourd'hui plus aucun riches
ne joue avec un jeu d'argent la plupart
du temps lem est quasi même les casinos
sont fréquentés par les pauvres mais le
vrai tournant dans le voit avec cette
cette publicité pour le loto de l'époque
voilà ça commence là ensuite
il va y avoir le deuxième tirage du loto
début des années 80 l'autorisation des
machines à sous dans les casinos et là
c'est plus les risques qu'ils jouent au
casino ça va être les pauvres et les
jeux à gratter dans les années 90
l'ouverture à la concurrence des jeux en
ligne dans les années 2000 et voilà
comment on en est arrivé là où on en est
ça s'est passé en un jour mais il a
fallu pour ça que l'état soit d'accord
exactement vous avez très bien résumé la
situation la chronologie en fait ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'on est passé dans
les trente glorieuses pour faire simple
les français ne s'intéressaient pas en
mon jeu
vous avez une habitude un certain nombre
d'habitudes dont le pmu
une consommation assez peu fréquentes il
s'en désintéresser même carrément pour
pour ce qui concerne la loterie et puis
petit à petit un certain nombre
d'innovations ont été autorisés on a
rajouté les tirages on a rajouté des
jeux et puis ça s'est accéléré au cours
de la période récente et vous avez
raison de souligner c'est vraiment une
volonté de l'état 1
donner c'est un calcul qui est fait
puisque on a une situation qui
fonctionnait assez bien et on a décidé
de relancer la passion du jeu à ce qu'on
appelle la passion du jeu prétendu les
français pour le jeu en réalité elle est
alimentée par parle est un qui ya vu un
intérêt alors on aura peut-être
l'occasion d'en reparler de l'intérêt de
l'état mais une des croyances qui est
partagée c'est que ça permet de générer
un certain nombre de taxes indolore et
donc c'est très avant de s' est perçue
comme très avantageux c'est mon
portefeuille qu'un on a on parle d'âne
apport volontaire sur les pauvres en
réalité puisque vous l'avez dit ce sont
surtout les classes populaires qui joue
surtout les jeunes enfin notamment les
jeunes plus exactement on va voir ça
dépend des jeux mais voilà il ya 45
milliards qui sont générées par l'impôt
sur le revenu ballet français qui
souvent d'ailleurs ne sont pas imposés e
miz 50 milliards tous les ans sur des
jeux divers et variés
oui effectivement les économistes
parlent d' impôt régressif par
imposition un impôt progressif et donc
la houle l'impôt sur le revenu a généré
45 milliards vous avez raison finalement
les français perdent on peut on peut on
peut dire d'une certaine façon
volontairement même si on va on va
rediscuter cette question de la volonté
j'imagine après ils perdent dans le jeu
et c'est un impôt régressif pourquoi
parce qu'en fait c'est les classes
populaires les déciles inférieur qui
cotisent le plus et les plus riches ne
joue pas aux jeux d'argent ou très peu
et en plus là où ça devient assez
problématique c'est que la répartition
des pertes de ceux qui jouent le plus en
fait sont proportionnellement plus
défavorisés plus précaires donc on a une
répartition inéquitable des dépenses qui
fait que c'est vraiment un impôt
régressif donc un impôt injuste ce qui
est amusant aussi on peut faire un autre
parallèle avec un autre type d'impôt
c'est l isf qui avait été supprimé et
qui en fait de générer le même
même volume environ 5 milliards et a à
peu près sur le même la même proportion
de
même nombre de deux personnes environ
300 milles et en fait on a trois d'un
côté on avait trois cent mille très
riche
qui générait 5 milliards et puis de
l'autre on a trois cent mille joueurs
problématiques qui génère à peu près les
mêmes les mêmes sommes et donc c'est
intéressant de faire le parallèle parce
que dans l'un d'un côté on estimer la
taxe injuste et de l'autre elle ne
semble pas vraiment posé de problème
dans le fond c'est pas du tout les mêmes
personnes dont on comprend bien que
c'est pas les mêmes personnes qu'on taxe
alors tous ces jeux qui existent
aujourd'hui qui se cumule à la fois dans
les casinos les paris en ligne paris
sportifs les jeux de grattage mais les
jeux de hasard pur
les laits et les capitaux qui existe
toujours ils ont tous en commun que plus
on joue plus on a de chances de perdre
c'est mathématique et en fait toute
l'astuce c'est de nous persuader du
contraire
c'est très juste effectivement de ces
hommes est une sorte de règle
universelle de tout opérateur de jeu il
faut vous faire rester le plus longtemps
possible vous engager dans le jeu
puisque les mathématiques sont du côté
du casino où les mathématiques sont du
côté de l'opérateur et donc il faut vous
faire rester le plus longtemps possible
il ya tout un tas de techniques alors ça
c'est des techniques qui sont présentes
hier dans les casinos savent très bien
comment vous fidéliser il a été sorti
dans un casino à las vegas n'a jamais
écrit sortie c'est déjà l'une des règles
on vous apporte des cigarettes quand
vous voulez fumée on vous fait pas payer
vos verres d'alcool etc etc mieux vaut
jouer en fait depuis ça s'est vraiment
les vieilles règles du casino de las
vegas
mais depuis on a vraiment bien travaillé
toutes ces méthodes la une que vous vous
en expliquer plein on va en voir plein
pour les paris hippiques
par exemple c'est l'illusion de l'
expertise en fait jouer de plus en plus
comme ça vous deviendrez expert en
devenant experts vous allez gagner
exactement c'est ça qui est mis en avant
c'est tout est entretenue pour donner
l'impression l'illusion qu'on va gagner
une sorte d' expertise et d'ailleurs
quand on regarde un peu les toutes les
publicités notamment du pmu qui sont
très bien faites là dessus on va
comparer le jeu d'argent à une sorte de
braquage donc on a une mise en scène du
joueur
qui parce qu'il a des tuyaux parce que
il a bien préparé il a fait le papier
comme on dit chez les turfistes
à une connaissance très fine du terrain
de des différentes dimensions qui
peuvent intervenir il a plu etc et donc
ça lui permet de prédire à coups reçus à
coup sûr les résultats et l'issue du sud
une issue du jeu alors évidemment c'est
vrai il peut exister une part de
d'habileté une parle de connaissances
qui peut jouer mais elle est souvent
très largement exagéré
on le retrouve aussi chez les parieurs
sportifs avec tout un tout le business
qui se développe autour des des
pronostiqueurs ceux qui proposent des
pronostics souvent payant
l'idée à chaque fois c'est qu'on va
gagner à tous les coups et donc on
propose cesser ces techniques pour
permettre aux joueurs de
en fait le but étant qu'ils jouent le
plus possible et pas vraiment qui gagne
évidemment
pour pour les loteries les les jeux de
grattage les paris en ligne c'est l'idée
que c'est l'illusion plutôt que le
jackpot est à portée de la main d'où
l'insistance constamment sur intel a
gagné les gagnants les gagnants regarde
et il a gagné dans votre département
dans votre bureau de tabac ailleurs ils
vous ressemblent ils vous ressemblent et
si lui a gagné vous aussi vous pouvez
donner
c'est ça le côté identification et être
très fort très important pour bien
montrer que
jouer à la fois cet ange ibles et c'est
aussi fait pour moi c'est quelque chose
qui me ressemble je sais en fait une
sorte de démocratie comme ça de la
seconde chance une mode d'allocation
alternative de ressources qui a un qui
est à la portée de tout le monde et
c'est intéressant comment comment fais
tu le
sais ces loteries
profite de cette déformation de la
probabilité qui va être engendrés par
ces publicités
yahia l'illusion du contrôle aussi c'est
à dire vous donner un très bon exemple
pour s'est aperçu que les joueurs de
craps aux états unis le jeu est très peu
développée chez nous donc qui consiste à
lancer des dés comme ça quand on veut
faire un gros chiffres si on veut 1,6 on
va jeter les dés très fort si en
revanche on veut faire un 1 ou un 2 on
va aller jeter très doucement évident
que ça n'a aucune influence puisque
combien on peut parfaitement on a autant
de chances d'avoir un enjeu temps forts
qu'eux que d'avoir un 6 et vice versa
mais donc on a quand on est joueur on a
l'illusion qu'on contrôle quelque chose
et elle et tous les paris tous les jeux
de hasard vont nous faire croire que
nous sommes habile comme on le fait
croire ou turfiste vous êtes habile vous
y connaissez vous connaissez le football
vous pouvez parier sur les matchs de
foot parce que vous êtes habile et on va
chez dr on va généraliser ça absolument
tous les jeux mais tout à fait sain
c'est un autre enjeu important non
seulement donc les la déformation des
probabilités mais là c'est l'idée de
jouer sur cette pente naturelle du
cerveau de nous de croire en fait qu'on
a là la possibilité de contrôler ce qui
ce qui va se produire de console est
contrôlée l'issue d'un jeu parce qu'on a
du mal à accepter le hasard en fait et
on a besoin de se donner l'impression
qu'on peut avoir une prise sur le
résultat souvent c'est aussi parce que
on ne comprend pas bien la mécanique de
jeu et tout effet entretenu tout est
fait pour entretenir
ses 7 7 nuls c'est ce défaut de
compréhension du mécanisme de jeu par
exemple sur une machine à sous vous
allez appuyer sur des boutons
des boutons il y en aura plusieurs il va
falloir essayer d'appuyer au bon moment
on donne l'impression qu'on a la
possibilité d'influer sur le résultat
alors que bien entendu ça n'a
strictement aucun impact
et c'est quelque chose qu'on retrouve
dans un truc dans tous les jeux et donc
vous avez raison on s'appuie sur cette
illusion qu'on le conte avait découvert
chez les joueurs de craps le fait qu'on
ou pense qu'on peut
influer sur le résultat et et bien
entendu ça ça va renforcer le goût pour
le jeu et ont forcé l'engagement du
joueur par exemple les machines qui sont
derrière moi
alors donc pas celle ci mais il y en a
beaucoup qui vous font croire que vous
jouez au poker on sait qu'il ya des très
bons joueurs de poker il ya un très bon
joueur de poker vous le battre et jamais
ce qu'il est les meilleurs que vous même
si vous avez un très bon jeu vous le
battrai pas donc le poker c'est une
habilité c'est un talent c'est à savoir
donc les jeux les machines comme ça
s'appelait en fait vous faire croire que
vous jouez au poker donc vous avez une
sorte d'habilité alors que c'est une
courbe de machines de jeux de hasard on
appuie sur un bouton et on pourra ré
appuyé quatre fois ce sera toujours du
hasard oui c'est un excellent exemple
que vous prenez pas ce que ces machines
à sous de poker électronique elles ont
été
elles ont d'ailleurs été accusé
notamment dans les pays anglo saxons en
australie on en trouve partout elles
sont vraiment accusé d'être à l'origine
d'une véritable épidémie l'addiction
dans ces pays là parce qu'elles sont en
fait conçu vous avez raison sur vraiment
une illusion l'impression qu'on jouait
du poker donc on peut contrôler les
résultats on va pouvoir utiliser notre
plus on joue plus on gagne de
l'expérience est meilleur on est alors
qu'en fait le design de jeu est
complètement repose sur du hasard et
l'interface qu'on a en face de soi les
images qui sont qui apparaissent ce qui
défile et en réalité complètement
déconnecté de l'algorithme qui est
derrière en fait de la mécanique de la
machine et ça c'est quelque chose de
très répandue de même on va encourager
la superstition par exemple les jeux jeu
qui s'appelle astro là c'est de la
superstition à l'état pur
ah oui complètement
et ça c'est intéressant on le voit on le
voit pas mal la française des jeux fait
beaucoup ça elle entretient la
superstition avec des cartes à gratter
qui vont porter les noms
des raisons dont castro il ya aussi
numéro fétiche etc et puis quand on va
sur le site de la française des jeux
souvent on va mettre en avant des
histoires liées aux superstitions pour
montrer que la superstition va peut-être
qu'on ne sais pas peut-être que ça ne
peut nous permettre de gagner donc il ya
vraiment ils vont entretient une culture
superstitieuse comme ça alors la plupart
des gens savent bien qu'une superstition
ça marche pas mais malgré tout on se
raccroche à 7 à ce petit rituel on salue
ça ajoute une peut-être une dimension un
peu ludique bon malgré tout ceux qui
sont les plus dépendants ont plutôt
tendance à avoir davantage de croyances
superstitieuses donc c'est pas
complètement anodin il s'agit aussi mais
ça les casinos l'ont inventé cazine
presque tout de suite c'est qu'il faut
transformer notre rapport à l'argent le
jeu tombe casino c'est fondamental à
partir du moment où on joue des jetons
même s'il ya écrit une valeur sûre ces
jetons on sait que ce sont des jetons
petite expérience si un moment dans les
années 80 on avait mis des plaques avec
des billets des francs à l'époque pas
dans les casinos à mais pour les
particuliers qui jouait chez eux au
poker et ses plaques représentait 2 500
francs de 100 francs 250 francs et déjà
les gens jouent moins quand ils ont des
jetons qui représente exactement les
billets de banque qui l'ont qu'ils ont
par ailleurs dans leur poche c'est moins
incitatif mais imagine aussi de monsieur
à la place des jetons on jouait avec des
vrais billets de banque c'est à dire que
sur l'étape des casinos il est vraiment
des billets de banque les gens à ce
moment là je vous aime beaucoup moins
donc il s'agit de métamorphoser
littéralement notre rapport à l'argent
de nous faire croire qu'on n'est pas en
train de jouer de l'argent voilà si on
avait ça sur un tapis vert de casino on
jouerait mois
tout à fait mais c'est effectivement une
stratégie un crucial parce que d'une
part on peut avoir un certain nombre de
réticences des réticences au jeu qui
sont liés a
malgré tout l'idée que jouer avec
l'argent peut-être que c'est pas
complètement anodin peut-être qu'on peut
avoir des réticences liées à des
croyances par exemple religieuse ça peut
ça peut être un frein donc le
jeton la dématérialisation
le rendre le que le la l'argent du jeu
fictionnelle d'une certaine façon ça
peut lever un certain nombre de
barrières morales par ailleurs vous avez
raison le une fois qu'on est dans une
session de jeu le fait de le
dématérialisé de le rendre finalement
c'est coût de l'argent un jeu plus
réglages de l'argent ça peut permettre
complètement d'oublier ce qu'on est en
train de faire et ça s'est envolé sur
les sites de pari en ligne par exemple
c'est quand même assez présent on va
avoir tendance
à jouer mais sans vraiment c'est
dématérialisée on ne manipule pas
l'argent qu'on sait c'est simplement
déclic
et donc ça va encourager
la pratique ça permet de faire oublier
aux joueurs qu'on mais il a perdu donc
ça c'est très important l'idée c'est
d'éviter que le joueur se rendent compte
de combien il a perdu sur une session de
jeu de combien il a perdu sur la semaine
sur le mois et c'est tout est fait pour
entretenir une sorte de flou on perd
d'un petit pelé la comptabilité de ce
conte ce qu'on a mis ce qu'on a misé
est-ce qu'on a
emporté et c'est donc ça c'est un enjeu
important pour les opérateurs de jeux et
c'est aussi un enjeu important pour la
pour les régulateurs parce que si on
informer vraiment les joueurs de ce
qu'ils ont perdu de la rentabilité de
tel ou tel jeu alors à ce moment là
le comportements serait quand même assez
freiné d'une certaine façon pourtant on
sait à peu près je crois que les
français en annonce perdre dans tous ces
jeux les français perdent 10 milliards
et c'est un tout à fait on le sait oui
les joueurs ne savent pas
personnellement
oui on le sait mais on ne leur dit pas
effectivement et et tous les flambeurs
vous expliqueront qu'à partir du moment
où on devient flambeur on n'a plus aucun
sens de l'argent bonjour oui
effectivement moi les joueurs que j'ai
rencontrés qui correspondent à ce profil
flambeur
vont avoir une conscience un peu
floue de ce qu'ils ont perdu sur des
années et c'est parfois ils vont me dire
des choses du style j'ai perdu une
maison c'est pas c'est pas très précis
et on perd le perd la notion de ce qu'on
a ce qu'on a perdu aussi parce que à un
moment donné l'argent il faut se
procurer de l'argent pour jouer et donc
cet argent aussitôt qu'il ait remporté
il va être dépensé donc il devient très
difficile de garder un une comptabilité
s'est même pas forcément recherché parce
que ses sources d'eau culpabilité aussi
donc le joueur n'a pas forcément envie
de maintenir une comptabilité précise
c'est pas le c'est pas le but et ça ça
va augmenter d'une certaine façon son
sentiment de culpabilité ou son mal être
donc il vaut mieux pas garder ça entre
eux présents à l'esprit dernier exemple
de comment rendre les jeux séduisant de
plus en plus séduisant ben on les rangs
et en les rendant inoffensif et quoi de
mieux pour les rangs des innocents
offensive qui ressemble à des jeux
enfantins à des jeux pour enfants et là
on a une dernière génération de jeux qui
arrivent on a vraiment l'impression que
ça s'adresse à des enfants c'est des
dessins à destination des enfants voilà
on en a juste derrière nous qui pourrait
penser que ce jeu là peut vous faire du
mal
c'est impossible il est forcément
inoffensif on peut en plus gagner de
l'argent avec là on arrive c'est ce
chef-d'oeuvre là à oui là c'est vraiment
spectaculaire quand on tombe dessus on
est bien frappé par le luth il isation
de dessins enfantins l'univers enfantin
les personnages anthropomorphiques et
donc on est vraiment dans le temps du
dans un univers à la disney ou dans des
données donc vraiment dans les livres
pour enfants ou les jeux les jeux vidéo
pour un enfant et finalement c'est vrai
ça ça au père ça a un effet en fait sur
sur les français sur sur les joueurs
notamment parce que on s'aperçoit que
l'interdiction qui est faite aux mineurs
moins de 18 ans de jouer aux jeux
d'argent en fait elle est très très peu
respectés l'initiation au jeu elle se
fait très jeune et beaucoup de parents
vont offrir ou vont permettre à leurs
enfants de débuter d'un jeu très très
tôt
parfois aussitôt que dix ans les enfants
vont tester leur premier apprendra à
gratter un ticket à gratter parce que
c'est un appareil d'une façon comme
inoffensifs mais eux par ailleurs c'est
ces jeux là sont pas jouées par des
jeunes enfants elle s'est jouée par des
adultes mais on peut dire que c'est de
la bonne publicité en fait tout ce qu'on
a vu là ce sont des bonnes manières de
nous faire jouer de nous faire aimer le
jeu de nous distraire en fait des
conséquences que cela peut avoir ça
s'appelle de la bonne publicité un
thomas amadieu ont fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après et on continue
d'explorer la fabrique j'allais dire la
fabrique du consentement la fabrique de
l'addiction aux jeux d'argent
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec le sociologue
thomas dieu qui est à shanghai et qui
publie la fabrique de l'addiction aux
jeux d'argent aux éditions du bord de
l'eau et c'est cette fabrique de
l'addiction qui nous intéresse dans
votre livre vous assistez sur le fait
que ce sont les classes populaires qui
sont ciblés alors on l'a bien compris
évidemment l'industrie du jeu veut nous
convaincre de jouer c'est normal le jeu
est légal donc ils veulent nous
convaincre de jouer tout ça n'a rien de
de très étonnant mais vous avez l'air de
dire qu'ils ciblent plus
particulièrement les classes populaires
qu'est-ce qui vous prouve le ciblage il
est d'abord il est évident quand on
observe les publicités à la façon dont
ces publicités sont
présentés alors on peut prendre
l'exemple des paris sportifs puisque
c'est le dernier exemple en date quand
on regarde l'univers qui est
mobilisée c'est celui pour faire simple
des jeunes et des jeunes des banlieues
où des jeunes des classes populaires
donc avec tout un ensemble de clichés
qui sont mobilisés et ce qui est
frappant c'est d'observer à quel point
ces concertée d'une certaine façon en
tout cas toutes les publicités se
ressemblent les par ailleurs les
opérateurs de paris sportifs que ce soit
par son site et les sans citer les noms
où vont tous adopté la même stratégie là
même les mêmes types de visuels ou
l'idée c'est vraiment de mettre en avant
la possibilité de
gagner un statut donc on cible plutôt
les plus tôt les hommes on va mettre
ensemble en scène des hommes va
reprendre tous les clichés de la
banlieue avec donc les tours
les scooters le tout un univers les
décotes des graffitis on va essayer de
mettre en place des campagnes qui vont
ceux qui vont se présenter comme
subversives et c'est donc tout ça en
fait ça c'est clairement
une forme de ciblage par ailleurs donc
on reprend les codes reprendre le
langage des jeunes des classes
populaires pour faire ça mais c'est pas
le seul type de ciblage puisque le
ciblage des classes populaires il est en
fait plus ancien que les paris sportifs
c'est pas nouveau c'est ce que fait déjà
ce que faisait la française des jeux et
au pmu déjà avant et donc c'est à ses
fins dans la façon dont c'est fait par
exemple on va mettre en avant on va
créer des jeux du type opération maison
où la caisse qui est ciblé en fait c'est
clairement l'idée qu' on sait que chez
les français il ya ce rêve des classes
populaires d'avoir une maison on joue
sur le
fait qu'une partie des classes moyennes
se paupérise sont dans des situations de
le pouvoir d'achat préoccupe est donc
tout ça va être assez finement ciblé par
ailleurs ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il ya
également la façon dont on organise les
points de vente où est ce qu'on les
place où est ce qu'on les positionne ça
on a pas mal d'études là dessus et donc
seulement en france mais c'est assez
universel on retrouve des points de
vente précisément là où il est il ya des
des classes populaires et en fait là les
points de vente pmu bas ils sont ils
vont être beaucoup plus présents là où
les classes populaires vivre où elle se
mêle évolue donc
c'est aussi une autre façon de cibler
au niveau marketing au sens large est
liée à l'esthétique costilla balade
d'ailleurs on voit une boutique pme il
ya une esthétique qui qui qui est
presque toujours la même oui il ya une
esthétique effectivement
d'ailleurs c'est assez frappante ses
points de vente française des jeux et
pmu sait sont souvent
le dernier
lieu de sociabilité qui existe dans pas
mal de coins de france en tant que dans
certains villages etc donc c'est devenu
ça fait partie du paysage
d'une certaine façon ça banalise et
parfois on a même des surprises des
choses un peu plus étrange qu'ils vont
encourager le jeu dans les classes
populaires par exemple un phénomène
assez intriguant c'est le fait que dans
les
machines les machines française des jeux
celle qui permet de valider son ticket
sont désormais utilisés pour faire un
certain nombre de payer ses impôts
notamment pour ceux qui n'ont pas accès
à internet chez eux ceux qui sont dans
une situation de grande précarité
peuvent utiliser les machines française
des jeux pour payer leurs impôts
littéralement et un certain nombre de
factures donc on va on va retrouver des
fautes et des services publics sur ces
machines fdj donc c'est assez surprenant
les jeunes c'est très frappant à la
façon dont les jeunes sont ciblés par
par les jeunes les jeux d'argent le
vocabulaire utilisé est un vocabulaire
jeunes à la limite il ya que les jeunes
qui peuvent comprendre pour le chope des
freebets avec les défis
ça veut rien dire à quelqu'un de 30 ans
effectivement c'est clairement ciblé
alors il ya on a par exemple ce qu'on a
vu tout à l'heure un grosse cote gros
gain de respect ce genre de vocabulaire
il et il va être réservé aux jeunes et
puis les jeunes vont pouvoir le
mobiliser ça va apparaître comme
subversif en quelque sorte parce que
c'est uniquement pour pour les jeunes ce
que peuvent le comprendre ils vont
ensuite être relayée sur les réseaux
sociaux avait écrit un certain nombre de
hashtag et d'influenceurs qui sont
financées par l'industrie du jeu ces
influenceurs qui ont un public jeune en
fait donc ils sont ils sont choisis ils
sont pas choisi par hasard le public de
ces influenceurs il est connu des
opérateurs de jeu est donc incertaine
d'influenceurs ou de célébrités vont
partager sur les réseaux sociaux sur
leur instagram sur twitter etc ils vont
avoir un certain nombre de followers et
ils vont relayer ce vocabulaire
spécifiquement pour jeunes mettent en
avant vous avez raison les freebet donc
les freebet on peut y revenir mais c'est
des bonus qui permettent d'ailleurs
d'avoir de l'argent ont fait en quelque
sorte gratuit d'obtenir de l'argent en
allant sur les sites de pari bon c'est
un peu plus compliqué que ça en réalité
pour obtenir
les freebet pour obtenir l'argent
gratuit il faut en réalité perdre pas
mal avant donc c'est souvent ça
s'apparente à une forme de manipulation
mais qui fonctionne assez bien et donc
oui c'est ça on cible les jeunes en
utilisant leurs canaux et les opérateurs
de jeux ont très bien réussi de ce point
de vue la rajeunir leur clientèle qui
était un petit peu vieillissante en
cours certaines en particulier je pense
aux plumes dont la population vieillit
c'est mais qui ont réussi à rajeunir la
population avec l'idée en plus qui
marche très bien avec les jeunes
notamment des classes populaires c'est
l'idée de battre le système l'idée de
faire un casse de faire un hold up qui a
été beaucoup développée par le pas le
pmu
l'idée de d'aller piquer le magot
ils ont parfaitement compris comment ça
fonctionnait
mais s'est s'inquiété qui a d'une
certaine façon au brillant mais en même
temps très très problématique parce que
disent les opérateurs de jeux arrivent à
se mettre du côté
finalement du joueur qui va déjouer le
système
et on lui permettrait en quelque sorte
s'il est très habile s'il est très
courageuse il fait preuve
d'audace il va pouvoir finalement dans
le système comme si les opérateurs de
jeux ne faisait pas partie du système
destiné d'une certaine façon alors
prélevé le prélever l'argent mais il ya
ce vocabulaire et ce resort populaires
du jeu comme une façon de bach le
système il est en fait très anciens les
opérateurs de jeux c'est à croire que
presque les opérateurs de jeu aurait lui
le sociologue richard hoggart qui
parlait de ça dans les classes
populaires des années des années 50 kiki
qui utilisait le jeu d'une certaine
façon c'était en grande bretagne ici et
je utiliser le jeu pour battre le
système est et c'est vraiment assez
vraiment frappant dans certains gâteaux
et d'esthétique qui rappelle le film
ocean's eleven avec
avec george clooney et brad pitt joue
justement alors 8 bat le système
puisqu'il arrive à cambrioler un certain
nombre de casinos or chose que personne
n'a réussi à le faire justement et c'est
pour ça que ça fait rêver tout le monde
et on emprunte à ce titre at t et
esthétique là c'est elle c'est à cette
philosophie là pour pour vendre la
capacité justement alors de de donner de
l'argent au système en allant jouer
le pmu tel est très loin avec des films
très très bien fait ou on voit
l'instinctif
l'experte voilà c'est présente
exactement comme des personnages de cr9
eleven ou d' ocean's twelve ou dos et 11
48 qui aurait battu le système et effet
agro case sur le pmu mais tout à fait
les publicités sont extrêmement bien
fait on met en scène différents profils
qui peuvent séduire des identifiants
pour différentes
types de jeux à l'instinct qui vous avez
raison ce liquide qui joue un peu au
feeling et puis celui qui va au
contraire cherché à tous toutes
élaborées qui a tout calculé tout
prédire qui est plutôt dans un profil on
pourrait qualifier de un entrepreneur et
ça a des effets opérant puisque quand on
interroge les jeunes et leur rapport aux
paris sportifs on s'aperçoit qu'en
réalité une grande partie d'entre eux
est persuadé qu' on peut gagner on peut
devenir riche grâce au jeu d'ailleurs
souvent ils ont eu la preuve via les
réseaux sociaux ils ont vu des gens qui
sont vraiment devenu riche grâce au jeu
et est alors qu'en réalité généralement
ce qui se passe c'est que les gens qui
deviennent risque riche grâce au jeu ce
sont en fait des influenceurs qui sont
financées par l'industrie du jeu pour
faire de la publicité pour les paris
sportifs et qui sont rémunérés par en
fonction du nombre d'inscrits qui
utilisent le code de l'influent soeur
pour s'inscrire sur la plateforme de
paris sportifs donc en été c'est
complètement illusoire mais vous avez
raison les publicités poussent dans ce
sens n'a
alors vous voyez dans tout cela un
problème de santé publique
moi j'aurais tendance à dire les jours
toujours existé
on a toujours perdu nul ne peut être
plus fort que le jeu lui même c'était la
devise de rollerball
le film d des années 70 on sait que
cette addiction au jeu on l'appelle la
diction aujourd'hui avant simplement ben
on était joueur et quand on était joueur
on savait que ça pouvait coûter très
très cher en faire à ce problème de
santé publique ça ressemble bien à notre
époque au fond j'ai envie de vous dire
alors c'est vrai qu'on peut d'une
certaine façon
une partie de l'addiction aux jeux qui
va correspondre à ce qu'on appelle la
médicalisation et c'est vrai que
médicalisé le jeu en faire une
pathologie
individuelles qui serait le produit d'un
certain nombre de prédisposition 20 à
voir
c'est vrai que c'est un langage qui peut
être un peu excessif et qui peut être
utilisé d'ailleurs par les opérateurs de
jeux qui vont y voir un certain nombre
d'intérêts notamment le fait que à
partir du moment où on considère qu'on a
1 1% de la population qui est addict aux
jeux qui a une maladie au jeu à partir
de ce moment là c'est pas la faute
vraiment des opérateurs c'est pas le
véritablement leur problème c'est plutôt
un problème qui est lié à la société ou
à l'être humain en général donc la
médicalisation en fait elle rend des
services aux opérateurs de jeux de façon
un peu paradoxal en revanche on peut
s'intéresser à la question de
l'addiction d'un point de vue plus plus
macro d'une certaine façon qu'est ce qui
se passe on s'aperçoit que vous avez
raison le jeu comme comme l'alcool comme
d'autres formes d'addiction avec avec
avec ou sans substance on pourrait dire
de cette façon a toujours existé c'est
quelque chose qui est lié à notre
constitution en tant qu'homme on a cette
prédisposition
notamment au niveau des circuits de la
récompense qui vont être activés et donc
on va rechercher un certain nombre de de
conduite qui nous procure ce plaisir et
on risque souvent on perd le contrôle
en tout cas une proportion de personnes
perdent le contrôle mais ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et qui est intéressant
malgré tout c'est de constater qu'on a
une accélération du phénomène et un
développement du phénomène qui est
absolument
spectaculaire et qui est également vous
l'avez rappelé au début on a quand même
un doublement en dix ans du nombre de
personnes qui ont un certain nombre de
problèmes liés au jeu et puis par
ailleurs donc c'est pas un phénomène qui
est uniquement liée à la france est donc
en réalité il faut il faut bien voir que
c'est
c'est pour ça qu'on peut parler d'une
sorte de problème de santé publique et
notamment parce que les problèmes de jeu
ils ont est également certain nombre de
conséquences qu'on commence à mesurer et
qu'on n'avait pas forcément
qu'on ne dirait pas auparavant par
exemple le fait que un joueur qui a des
problèmes du jeu a une probabilité 15
fois plus forte de se suicider
on sait également que 1/3 des joueurs
qui ont des problèmes de jeu vont
exercer des violences conjugales on sait
également que on a une sur
représentation des personnes qui ont un
problème de jeu dans les prisons donc ça
a l'air on sait que ça induit un certain
nombre de conduite criminelle et c'est
donc on s'est même un certain nombre d'
enquête qui montre que la mortalité va
augmenter de 37% quand on a une habitude
de jeu intensif ça c'est une enquête
intéressante évitez fait de même à dieu
brut 1 si vous avez lu dos tf qui vous
saviez tout ça déjà le joueur nous
expliquait déjà que quand on était
joueur on avait toutes les chances
d'avoir les problèmes que vous venez de
décrire ont pas besoin d'en quête pour
le savoir le problème c'est que ou
plutôt un avantage à l'époque c'est que
ça touchait que les privilégiés
[Musique]
mais le problème ça s'est démocratisé au
fond il fut un temps où il y avait que
des riches qui avait ce genre de
problème et ben maintenant les pauvres
l'ongle un de plus que les riches ça
s'est démocratisée cg imposant que c'est
ça qui choque mais au fond tout s'est
démocratisé et c'est même l'enjeu du
capitalisme c'est de tout démocratiser
pour que tout devienne marchandises pour
le plus grand nombre de consommateurs
possible le jeu compris oui d'incidents
un point de vue vous avez raison le
développement d'une société de
consommation et la démocratisation
finalement des des jeux d'argent à
massifier le phénomène de l'addiction
donc ça c'est assez c'est tout à fait
juste alors depuis de dostoïevski on a
quand même appris un certain nombre de
choses en plus mais c'est vrai que cette
cette addiction qui se répand dans
l'ensemble du corps social elle est liée
aux également à une évolution des jeux
eux-mêmes dans vous avez raison les les
jeux d'argent finalement ont toujours
créé ont pu créer de l'addiction mais
les jeux contemporains sont quand même
singulièrement beaucoup plus présent
qu'il ne l'était au 19e siècle si vous
voulez à l'époque c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles ça ne touchait que les
qu'une partie des classes supérieures
mais pour aller jouer il fallait que
malgré tout aller dans un certain nombre
de villes d'eaux
[Musique]
effectivement des vides
et avoir un smoking n'entrez pas qui
vous qui voulez il fallait un certain
nombre de fonds pour pouvoir investir il
rentrait dans le casino mais aujourd'hui
ce qui se passe et qu'on peut jouer
littéralement partout on peut jouer sur
son téléphone on peut jouer 24 heures
sur 24 on n'a pas besoin de bouger de
ces de chez soi on peut jouer au coin de
la rue aux pme c'est la tendance c'est
la surabondance de l'offre que vous vous
dites
voilà mais mon frère comment faire pour
limiter l'offre alors pour limiter là
bas on fait on assez simple puisqu'on a
on a pas mal d'outils déjà à notre
disposition puisque en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'on a à chaque fois qu'on
a autorisé
de nouveaux jeux par exemple au moment
de l'ouverture à la concurrence des jeux
et paris en ligne en 2010 quand cette
loi a été votée on a obligé la création
à créer un régulateur donc une instance
qui est censée être indépendante et qui
est censé fixer un peu les règles du jeu
décider quel type de jeu et sont
autorisés quels sont les opérateurs
autorisés et aujourd'hui on a ce qu'on
appelle l'autorité nationale des jeux là
angie qui accorde un certain nombre de
2 022 et autres dérogations en quelque
sorte pour laisser aux opérateurs le
soin de proposer leurs jeux donc chaque
jeu qui est qui entrent sur le marché en
réalité c'est un peu comme les
médicaments si vous voulez ils doivent
faire l'objet d'une d'un contrôle et ils
sont autorisés pareil pour les
publicités et dans ce qui est
intéressant c'est que cette autorité
nationale je vais en fait à l'aller
moyens si elle veut elle peut tout à
fait établir un certain nombre de règles
pour réduire cette ce phénomène de
l'addiction jeu par exemple elle peut
alors c'est beaucoup en discussion
actuellement à ce qu'il faudrait limiter
la publicité est ce qu'il faudrait
mieux informer les joueurs bon il ya des
débats autour de ça au sein de
l'autorité nationale du jeu elle ne
semble pas très pressé de prendre des
décisions fortes l'oralité à laleu un
pouvoir assez assez large notamment de
par exemple de limiter de faire un
moratoire sur les nouveaux jeux et
d'essayer d'évaluer voilà l'offre qu'on
a actuellement est ce qu'on peut pas
essayer de réfléchir à
la façon dont on propose de nouveaux
jeux est ce qu'on peut pas proposer des
jeux soit moins addictif partent avec
des mises maximales par exemple
comme ava dieu se serait pas juste c'est
comme sur dix est bon maintenant aller
il ya trop de voitures on va limiter aux
marques qui existe déjà tesla non
voilà vous arrivez trop tard on peut pas
réduire on peut pas dans un souci
d'équité dire que seuls ont le droit de
se partager le gâteau ceux qui étaient
là avant c'est déjà ce qui se passe en
réalité c'est bien ce qui se fait chaque
ou de nouvel opérateur
en fait il ya une limitation du nombre
d'opérateurs au moment de l'ouverture à
la concurrence on a vu apparaître plein
de nouveaux opérateurs mais en réalité
ils ont été vite éliminé parce que le
marché a été organisée de sorte que ce
soit plutôt oligopolistique qui inquiète
un certain nombre d'opérateurs a ses
limites et qui sont généralement
des groupes assez puissant désormais on
a par exemple derrière parions sport qui
induit des applications de paris
sportifs c'est la fdj derrière mini mac
sont à stéphane courbit qui est
un grand industriel on à betclic on a un
certain nombre d'opérateurs qui est très
limitée en réalité donc on n'est pas du
tout dans un ghetto c'est aussi une
manière d séparent dos est aussi une
manière d'écarter les les bandits les
méchants les illégaux c'est qu'on fait
confiance à des gens qu'on connaît à des
groupes qu'on connaît qui ont pignon sur
rue
oui oui c'est ça le d'ailleurs la
justification de l'autorisation de
l'ouverture la confiance ça a été de
dire on veut éviter qu'ils aient trop de
jeu illégal et donc il faut qu'on laisse
un certain nombre d'opérateurs très bien
encadré qui sont des opérateurs
responsables
le soin de proposer des jeux qui soit
inoffensif et plutôt raisonner qui
protège bien les joueurs des dérives
liées à la diction et puis aussi des
dérives liées au blanchiment d'argent et
puis qui me qui naquit nous qui ne
sommes pas dans une démarche d' arnaque
ou ce genre de choses donc c'est ses
salles à la rationalité qui à l'arrière
mais en fait qu'est-ce qu'il est le
bilan au bout de dix ans de
l'ouverture
au marché finalement on a une
augmentation de l'addiction qui est un
peu hors de contrôle on a des pratiques
publicitaires qui sont très loin de
notions d'éthique et qui éviterait de
cibler par exemple des populations
vulnérables
voilà donc on est on est assez loin ce
qu'on fait de la rationalité de ce qui
est proposé à l'origine donc d'avoir un
marché qui soit responsable qu'ils
soient qu'ils canalisent en fait la
passion du jeu et qui évite aux jeunes
par exemple d'aller jouer en ligne sur
des sites illégaux mais moi je trouve
être un livre très intéressant justement
c'est y compris pour les gens qui
seraient tentés de jouer de comprendre
comment on va essayer de les faire jouer
plus ou différemment de ce qu'il
voudrait comment on les séduit comme on
les détourne de leur voix ça c'est très
intéressant mais pas partout le moment
on voudrait réguler tous à interdire
interdire par exemple au jeu de
s'améliorer interdire la publicité
interdire interdire interdire pour cette
édition s'appelle interdit d'interdire
ces bar hazard j'ai l'impression qu'à la
fois c'est voué à
l'échec on voit bien d'ailleurs la
prohibition de la drogue n'a fait
qu'encourager la prise de drogue on n'a
jamais eu autant de drogue elle n'a
jamais été aussi facile à trouver elle
n'a jamais été aussi peu cher jamais été
aussi forte et pourtant ça fait des
décennies qu'on lutte contre la drogue
donc qu'est ce que vous voulez faire la
même chose avec les jeux que ça
redevienne temps destin
héros c'est quand ces clandestins c'est
beaucoup plus dangereux encore puisque
la drogue elle est plus frelaté que si
elles étaient nous était vendue par
l'état
non vous avez tout à fait raison c'est
absolument pas souhaitable d'être dans
une interdiction totale ou une
profession c'est complètement illusoire
et c'est pas du tout possible en réalité
il ya un entre deux c'est à dire que
l'on n'est pas l'idée n'est pas du tout
d'interdire la au contraire de revenir à
un jeu qui soit véritablement amusant
qui soit véritablement
passionnant et qui soit pas un jeu qui
réorganise et par un certain nombre de
grands groupes qui utilisent ce qu'ils
utilisent des tout un tas de techniques
qu'on a bien décrit précédemment pour en
fait manipuler les joueurs et ce qui se
passe souvent chez ses joueurs c'est que
en réalité
contrairement aux jeux d'argent on va
dire
qui sera plus plus sociale et qui sera
plus
conviviale on a plutôt un jeu dans
lequel
le plaisir ressenti est finalement assez
faible et ce qui va dominer chez les
joueurs souvent c'est la frustration de
ne pas avoir gagné la frustration de
promesses déçues parce que les promesses
de gains les promesses de
valorisation soit les promesses de
changer de statut finalement elles sont
pas
ne sont pas remplies elles sont pas
tenues donc c'est c'est à ça qu'il
faudrait plutôt réfléchir donc non pas
interdire mais oh mais plutôt à essayer
de réfléchir à comment on peut éviter
7,7 pouces et incontrôlée est largement
qui repose largement sur en fait des
manipulations ne s'est pas l'idée n'est
pas du tout de l'interdire le jeu et ça
ne fonctionnerait pas essayer c'est
vraiment
impossible et même sur le plaisir que
ressentent ses joueurs c'est très
difficile les grands joueurs je parle
des joueurs de casino n'a pas des
joueurs de jeux de grattage mai mais les
joueurs de casino vous diront que leur
grand plaisir c'est pas tellement gagner
de l'argent c'est de récupérer de
parvenir à récupérer ce qu'ils ont perdu
voilà quelque chose d'assez
incompréhensible pour ceux qui ne jouent
pas par exemple et ben voilà ce serait
au fond c'est pas de gagner c'est pas de
ressortir avec plus d'argent c'est de
ressortir avec l'argent qu'on avait
perdu qu'on est parvenu à récupérer donc
qu'est-ce qui va se ficher dans la tête
du joueur y compris du joueur qui joue 2
euros
dans son bureau de tabac c'est compliqué
de savoir oui c'est compliqué mais en un
certain de donner là dessus donc on
s'est un peu ce qui ce qui fonctionne et
est notamment ce que vous décrivez à
juste titre le fait de vouloir se
refaire c'est un classique de l'un des
traits caractéristiques de ce qu'on
appelle l'addiction au jeu c'est qu'à un
moment donné on ne joue plus tellement
pour vraiment changer de vie ou
s'enrichir là on joue parce qu'on n'a
plus vraiment le choix en réalité on est
tellement endettés on est tellement on a
tellement perdu que quitter à ce moment
là le on a mis le doigt dans l'engrenage
et si on quitte le jeu si on se retire
du jeu qu'on devient
qu'on abandonne d'une certaine façon on
a perdu à jamais ce qu'on a misé donc il
ya un certain nombre pour un certain
nombre de joueurs c'est comme s'il avait
rempli une tirelire et qu'à un moment
donné il espère pouvoir la casse et
malheureusement c'est ce qui entretient
donc c'est d'une certaine façon c'est ça
sa rationalité s'est pas complètement
irrationnel même si le résultat il est
clairement celui d'une conduite auto
destructrice parce que ça peut ça peut
pas bien se finir merci thomas radieux
alors passer toute cette émission avec
nous la fabrique de l'addiction aux jeux
d'argent votre livre vient de paraître
aux éditions du bord de l'eau merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]